(ambient music)
(cheering crowd)
- [Gary] Morning.
What are you doing in 2017
environment that's actually
gonna help you sell more homes,
bring more awareness,
build your business,
build your brand?
What are those strategies,
what are those implications?
Jab, jab, jab, right hook, and
the thank you economy are both
still very underutilized
by the market.
People continue to put
out content that is in high
percentage in their best
interest and not in
the value of the end user.
The number one shift that
everybody has to do in this room
is understand the following
statements and understand it
cold, not just shake your head
when you hear the words
coming out of my mouth.
The quicker you understand in
this room that you are a media
company-comma-real estate agent,
real estate software provider,
whatever you may be.
I know that I am a media
company-comma-an agency CEO.
A wine retailer.
Once you make that
shift everything changes.
11 years ago nothing that we
talk about in society existed.
Not Netflix, not YouTube,
not smartphones, not Facebook.
Zero.
If you are not digitally
native you will die.
And what I mean by that is
not the will die that you'll go
directly out of business it's
just the people that are
are going to take your business.
The world changes and the
biggest part that I'm worried
about is that the world is
changing in a much bigger way
that you and or I realize.
This is about a binary decision
of are you understanding how
important digital
is or are you not?
And more importantly making
your actions map your words.
Thank you.
(applause)
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
- [Man] Gary, you
ruined my life.
- [Gary] How so?
- [Man] Because I didn't do
video until a year ago--
- [Gary] Yes and now?
- Putting out 35 a month--
- [Gary] And it's
your whole world.
- and I look at you and I'm like
this mother fucker better not
put another video out and
I go online and you do so I do.
- [Gary] I love it.
- [Man] Can I get a
picture with you?
- [Gary] Yeah, let's do it.
Awesome.
- You're the man.
Thanks for the inspiration.
- [Gary] Take care.
- If I wanted to hire
an army of people,--
- Yes.
- where would you, how
would you start to do that?
- First, you need to be
educated so the first thing.
- [Man 2] I got that.
Five hours a day.
- [Gary] Do that because then
when you list it or you put it
out on LinkedIn wherever
you put it you'll know
what you're looking for.
The problem that people make is
they go I'm not going to hire
24-year-old kid to do this
for me but they
have no fucking idea.
If you don't have any idea you
don't know what to look for.
You don't know if you're
getting ripped off,
if it's effective or not.
Educate yourself and then very
simply there's unlimited places
to get people.
There's job listings for social
media everywhere in the world.
- Is that a Craigslist thing?
- Yeah, I would literally put in
social media job listings like
on Google and you
would find 400 things.
- Okay.
- Alright?
- Thank you so much.
- You're welcome.
Morning, hi.
- You have changed my life.
- Thank you.
- Your content I've more
than quadrupled my income.
My perspective on things, the
way that I teach agents it all
comes from you.
- Thank you so much.
- I'm gonna cry.
It's literally changed my life.
I'm so grateful for
this opportunity.
- Thank you so much.
That means the world to me.
- [Man 3] One, two, three.
Here you go.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you so much.
Thanks for all you do.
- Can we do an excited face?
- Yes.
- Awesome.
- Thanks so much.
- Nice meeting you.
Yes, take care of yourself.
- Nice to meet you.
Are you losing belief or
are you just wish
it was happening faster?
- [Woman] Just wish it
was that happening faster.
- Well, you need to buck
up and be more patient.
- [Woman] Yeah?
- Yeah, entrepreneurship is
a lifestyle, not a tactic.
It's forever.
There's ups, there's downs.
There's a quote I always say
that entrepreneurship is
like UFC, everybody loses.
You're a young woman.
You're gonna have
many more at-bats.
Being hungry and wanting to win
is very important but all that
ambition needs to be
equally balanced with patience.
And patience is hard.
- More patience.
- I'm so fucking
excited right now.
- [Gary] Thank you, man.
- I can't even tell you.
- Thank you, brother.
- I'm getting
married in a month.
- You are?
Congrats.
- My fiancé is like you're
probably more excited to
meet GaryVee today--
- (laughs) Than get married.
- I'm like I'm not answering.
- You're like, "I can't
hear you honey."
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- "I can't hear you."
- What's that?
What's that?
- Go ahead, I'm listening
to your question.
- So, how do you
leave ego at the door?
- I don't, I just--
- I know you had that Australian
guy, right who gave you shit for
undercutting his wine sales.
- Yes.
- And he asked you to
be on his show and
then you went on his show.
- No, no. He asked to be
on my show and I put him--
- Oh, he asked to
be on your show?
Oh shit.
- I put him on my show.
Even bigger.
- Right.
- Dude, negativity has no value.
- Absolutely.
- Ego is
different than a grudge.
- Okay. Okay.
- Got it?
To me, a grudge is negative.
To me, an ego is positive.
- Well fuck, look at
Fat Joe now, right?
- Yeah. He's positive now.
- He's on the show, right?
- I know. That was fun.
- I said, you know what,
I'm gonna eliminate
all obstacles.
Put all ego and pride
aside and let me just
try the non-ego route.
And see how this works and
so far we're platinum on the
single, going to
double platinum.
Yeah, yeah--
- Go with positivity, imagine that.
- It's a magical miracle
pill that seems to be working.
- Yeah, it happens.
My man.
- Gary.
- Thank you.
- Much love man.
Thank you so much
for everything.
- Stay well, take
care of yourself.
Good luck to you.
(fire alarm)
- [Woman 2] Cue the fire alarm.
- [Man 4] Let's do it.
- Let's do it.
Oh, we're going video?
- [Man 4] Here we go,
here we go.
Everyone in?
- [Gary] Blowing up.
- [Woman 2] Set
the house on fire.
It's a weird life.
- Isn't it weird?
- It's weird but
it's so flattering.
- Yeah.
- People are always
like, "Oh, do you hate it?"
I'm like, "Hate it? It's like
the nicest thing ever."
People like you enough to be
excited to take a
picture with you.
It's the greatest.
- [Woman 3] All those grown
men were like little girls.
- [Woman 2] They were, they
were fawning all over you.
I'm never seen
something like that.
- And I'm huge with
40-year-old dudes.
- [Man 5] Center marker's there.
(fire alarm)
(group groans)
- Just waiting for
the fucking alarm.
(group laughter)
- [Loudspeaker] May I have
your attention please,
may I have your
attention please?
The San Francisco Fire
Department has investigated the
alarm and has
declared it's a false.
Please proceed with
business as usual.
- Sure.
- [Man 5] Count to 10 for me.
- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 9, 10.
- [Man 5] That's the level
you're gonna be speaking?
- Yes.
- [Man 5] Okay.
- Probably around this level.
- [Man 5] Right on this level.
One more time.
- 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 9, 10.
- [Man 5] Okay,
great, thank you.
- I never say eight.
- [Woman 4] Right, here we go.
What advice do you have for a
real estate agent who is just
now starting on social media?
What platforms, techniques
or general approach
would you recommend?
- My biggest advice right now
for real estate agents jumping
into social media whether
they're in the 101 phase or the
201 phase is to
take it seriously.
This is a binary game,
this is not about a tactic.
This is not about me saying
use hashtags on Instagram or
Facebook Live matters or pay
attention to Snapchat this is
you either understand that your
customers' attention is in these
spaces or you don't.
You either believe in the
digital revolution or you don't.
It's a one and zero game and so
I think my biggest advice would
be get into it deep.
- [Woman 4] Thanks so much Gary.
That was awesome.
- [Gary] Of course.
(upbeat music)
Hey, how are you?
Big day, obviously the
Apple announcement.
Been sitting on that
for a little while.
Here it is.
Gwyneth Paltrow and Will.i.am
join reality series
"Planet of the Apps".
I love this.
I love the whole way
it is being positioned.
Why did they get
linked and I don't.
(DRock and Gary laughing)
Oh, wait a minute, be careful,
there's a picture of me.
After season one
it's going to be,
"Hey do you watch
GaryVee's show?"
- Yeah.
- Super excited.
Obviously, spent the last six or
seven years, eight years,
nine years passing on
opportunities to do
television shows and other
shows so finally found the one
that I thought made
sense for me.
Couple speeches, couple
business opportunity meetings,
an investor meeting.
You know, VaynerMedia, GaryVee,
VaynerCapital just
living my life.
(upbeat music)